[Music]  what make a man brave a blizzard killed  in cold blood I'm sure I don't know  you'd be surprised what a man would do  start see pictures ain't you got room  for one more  I ain't too anxious to be handin out  right  real trust in fella huh not so much he  no way I'm spending a couple of nights  under a roof with somebody I don't know  who they are so who are you  [Music]  ok everybody hear this I'm taking this  woman to hang rewards $10,000 that  money's mine boys oh that's interesting  yeah I'll make a who's with that fella  uh-huh  that's my problem boy I don't know  one of them felts will kill everybody in  here now we're talking  let's slow it down let's lowered way  down  mining it to hell tell him Daisy sent  you  you don't know  no one said this job's supposed to be  easy  nobody's supposed to be their heart  neither  [Music]